I think you'll like this I did that was  the best thing that ever happened to me  what a surprise mr. Spicoli isn't them  again Joel's lazy Glendon lazy you're a  drug dealer Dalton how can you tell me  what's right and wrong in a frog for a  long time photographer often analyzing a  business office is the CIPA Rights  Ordinance we have to leave everyone  shame on you you call yourself a  reporter or because you were feeling  lonely  did it ever occur to you that maybe you  are seeing just exactly what you wanna  see because they have all the power but  I have my word some people are meant to  be hot I don't know  all I know is but if you can't see this  is  they harass a river down and I thought  they might give you coke